ich werde mich hätte cracks zu blöd
connect auf doch ich dachte auch noch
craig ist blöd und fr
er dreht sich drei mal hallo meine
lieben freunde und herzlich willkommen
zurück bei minecraft hero noch gucke ich
mir schon wieder unscharf mein video auf
an alle die jetzt die letzte war ihr
müsst mit kommt alle die letzte folge
guckt haben und jetzt direkt weiter
gucken wissen ich war letzte folge meine
schwester kocht ich war letzte folge
unscharf aber das ist irgendwie immer so
geradezu zeitweilig den fokus mal auf
automatisch gestellt habe und nächste
folge ist besser sein wenn ich dann
scharf sein da will ich das nicht mehr
machen hoffe ich wollte jetzt noch eine
folge aufnehmen weil ich mir jetzt eine
trial rüstung machen wollte übrigens
gefällt euch das besser nicht das mikro
nicht so direkt vor der presse habe vom
von vom klang her jetzt und mexikanische
nacht kommt ich nehme jetzt einfach mit
ich lasse euch jetzt mal ganz kurz hier
oder oder sind die wohl auch so schnell
und mit komplett sind die nicht höher
blöden club weg von neuen krieg nie
wieder märchen
ich werde jetzt wird mit diesem gesicht
wieder irgend ein verkappter facebooks
mai die erstellt es ist so heftig wie
viele facebook smileys von simon lena
und mir gibt also wir sind somit die
einzigen die sich bisher gezeigt haben
also doch es haben sich so alle gezeigt
aber irgendwie von anderen leuten ab
jetzt nicht so von tadel habe ich noch
eins mit sexy gesehen voll mit mir gibt
so langweilig mit simon gibt's alles so
läuft bei dir alles wirklich einfach aus
einem stream halt alles so ausgeprägt
ich mag das eigentlich gar nicht zu also
an viele leute feiern das so richtig mit
diesen ganzen smileys und bildern
ich war ja auch so bilde aber wer das
von mir gemacht wird wie ich das immer
so
bisschen unwohl meine lippe tut weh
bisschen unwohl bei aber sind ja direkt
wieder zu hause nur da hinter den hügeln
zwischen da ich sehe schon mal in meiner
ganzen birne ist gar nicht das unseren
komische andere welt
foto foto los komm jetzt für tolle macht
etwas wie sixt und verpiss dich
fotos und servus der anderen krank
schreibt male klagten kommt an
und wenn ihr sie schreiben könnt dann
macht euch ein google schneit das heißt
bei uns regnet wenn ich eigentlich bei
mir schnee auslege ist dann bei mir auch
schnee weil ich hätte folgen schnee auf
meinem grundstück wende zur
weihnachtszeit die stars dann mache ich
auch einen schönen baum in die stadt
glaube ich muss auch manchmal also ich
habe jetzt ich habe die aufgabe weil das
sich essensversorgung mache deswegen
glaube ich meine riesige schweinefarm
minnelli und die machen alle mit cortado
und craig die machen einfach inzest und
dann kriminalität sprechen kommt jetzt
mit
die letzten metern verpackten die hier
wieder so richtige schweine eine prima
ich werde mich hätte cracks zu blöd
oh doch ich dachte auch noch quick stop
loss und fr
er dreht sich drei meinen kräften
verlassen hier ist richtig gute stimmung
wenn ich wiederkomme ist ich will mal so
labyrinth jungs queck der fällt in jedes
lokal jetzt ist einfach im boden klopp
sechs geistig behindert für die wg
übrigens auch sehr cool die hier gemacht
wurden was das hier ist weiß ich nicht
alles cool ich mag unsere stadt von
allen städten am meisten irgendwie es
gibt ja nur so kommentare irgendwie ich
weiß nicht ob das bei euch usern nur so
ist oder ob das nur bei mir steht und
zwar es wird immer so geschrieben dass
bei statt gelb nahezu gar keiner guckt
anni statt gelb also unsere stadt und
simon stadt die werden so am meisten
geguckt und das bei der anderen stadt
weiß niemand so richtig was da überhaupt
so los ist bei denen ich weiß nicht
warum aber irgendwie kommen bei mir ist
gar kein richtiger weg gelegt doch prof
ich glaub ich auch noch mal um oder soll
ich machen sie nicht einfach nicht mein
chocobos übrigens auch wahrscheinlich
gestorben dann kommt die hierdurch ja du
kommst da durch
könnt ihr nicht durch muss da reingehen
wo hinein hier ein wenig beim vierten
die tür kaputt und da machen wir
sichtbar ist nicht doof um scharf ich
krieg das aber auch nicht weg kommen
ich muss jetzt wohl nicht einen box und
von euch oder doch jetzt habe ich zwei
mädchen
ich hab mir läuft es zum live soll ich
jetzt kurz denn damit ich hier mit ihren
damit der regen aufhört so jetzt mache
ich mir eine hexe carl scheiße hier
denkmal wieder noch einige ein soll 34
19 platzierten 124 124 124 124
dann war ein thema das thema ein
bisschen ist da noch ein wenig mit
drogen mit ihr kommt auf einen sonst
habe ich gar nichts wertvolles
doch das essen ist gut
nehme habe ich auch wirklich gar nicht
hallo
auch black is like ein bisschen an den
zwei watt in tokio fehler den er hat mir
mein gold geht auch gar nicht
zurückgegeben irgendwie und ich hab dir
einfach verloren weil gold wäre das echt
wichtig für mich weil ich halt nicht
gestorben wenn ich eine gehabt hätte so
eine feder doch da ist die feder
so hab ich euch einfach hier alle rein
diese alter arm in arm bis z wie das tut
es einfach mal ganz kurz team eine
ordnung die ich als sonst auch mal habe
ich beeile mich schon tut mir leid
dauert nun mal ein bisschen alter mann
das heck ein d-zug so triebel leder
leder und eisen bäume menge
ich hatte hier leder drin nada kleider
wen hast du ne genannt
ich bin zu blöd schreibt mir mal wie ich
das so da jetzt da rein bekomme so dass
sich dass das rezept da so drin liegt
weil das weiß ich immer noch nicht kann
sein dass wir da schon geschrieben ob da
was kommt wie so viele kommentare immer
es ist halt dann blöd da die
hinterherzukommen knochen knochen ich
noch nie der fall schon wird rasch immer
rasch löschen
als auch keine knochen habe was sollen
dass sie ihre ich habe einfach keine
knochen okay gut was andere so da müsse
darlegen
kabul die hose hier auf jeden fall auch
schon mal die füße aber strings
festrings habe ich aber trinks
trinks dringen hektik ja aber die
schützen
sodann kann ich die anderen
rüstungsteile ich immer schon mal rein
tun können nämlich dass von hier oben
mag ich dann auch hier oben ein feuchter
noch nie war da am noch dann da sein so
ich brauche was brauche ich denn da für
den nur knochen fünf knochen
ich darf bei keinem an die kisten gehen
deswegen werde ich jetzt wahrscheinlich
ich werde mal bei erkämpft bei dem spor
nach vorne
vielleicht ist das allerdings bonner
dabei wenn knochens ponor 80
ich bin behindert skeletts bonner da ist
oder so ich wollte das jetzt mal ganz
kurz hier so scheiße nicht dass danach
richtig 48 dollar jungs ich hoffe dass
bald etwas was ist der tag hält deswegen
ich weiß nicht ob das passt von dem
nicht lange her dass porta gar nichts
naja dann müssen wir ganz kurz in die
höhe gehen
oder ich nehme mir einfach kommen ich
nehme einfach becker jetzt eben 50
rappen ein schildchen schulter genommen
habe aber vielleicht hat er auch in
seiner thron er hatte nicht nur die
teams karlsruhe
irgendwie kommt mir jetzt einfach mal 5
1 2 3 4 5
wenn sich keppler in die beschweren
sollte oder so dann weil er sich bei mir
melden skype dass ich mir halt immer so
sachen neben darf wenn die welt halten
nichts wert von 75 knochen kann ich mir
jetzt auch selber zusammen fanden
einfach keine geduld in der höhle zu
gehen dann so viele skelette zu suchen
dass ich ein fünftel offen bekomme ich
das jetzt die version kann euch dann die
triebe rüstung mal vorstellen
meine damen und herren hier kommt die
maus mit gedrückter stimmung war zwei
mal so ein bisschen
allerdings ich habe night vision stärke
und shampoos 3 vor allem der jump das
richtig gut ich kann
warte mal ich kann drei blöcke
hochspringen 33 blöcke hoch nicht ein
shampoos 3 ist ja ich vier berge hoch
springen wie sonst kann ein hoch
springen dann shampoos 2011 ist ja dann
zwei blöcke jump u2 sind drei blöcke und
jump boost 433 sind vier tempus 304
ich denke ich hätte mir jede rüstung mal
machen weil ich habe ja nicht so viele
existenzen allerdings dass jetzt sitze
ich möchte auch muss aufpassen dass die
öffentliche bühne bis der bescheid
schokowelt auch noch eben holen
manchester auch leider weg q/q und pack
die bag
welches der beste weg das dann rufen wir
sind sattel string leder golde festring
leder schuh coburg feder string relativ
egal
so nochmal aller kraft den rezepte hier
immer falsch da so und jetzt macht mir
einfach ich mache mal die hier jetzt die
andere sieht leichter aus also dies
leichter tun dies weil die schwieriger
zu machen ich nehm jetzt einmal die
frage zeichnet ich verstehe es frage
zeit nicht da steht immer so ja hier
könnt ihr tipps geben dann klickt man
darauf und es kommen einfach keine tipps
auch nur eine wolle weil mach jetzt ich
habe noch drei strings alter was los
hier bei mir im sommerschlussverkauf
1345 weg so ich schreibe jetzt erstmal
ganz kurzen schild dass ich mir bei ihm
ein wolle und also ich werde auf jeden
fall noch eine rolle bei ihnen holen
ein wolle und eine wolle
und noch etwas
hab mir ein wolle und was waren das noch
fünf knochen bei dir geborgt danke lucca
so hier ein
hat er denn einwohner für mich besser
vielleicht wär' doch glaube ich ua ich
glaube kempf hat auch alle sachen
eigentlich auch so aus links aushöhlen
sich allerdings recht geholt das ist
klar da waren aber auch gerade schon
strings aber der keine freunde keine
freunde jetzt eigentlich so und werden
freunde ich nehme jetzt einfach ein
string das ist gar kein string das ist
ring soll dann mache ich mir daraus eben
einen wolle so jetzt muss ich mal ein
bisschen auf die uhr gucken wollen
shokof jeder leder natürlich wieder
lehne auch ich wollte mehr strings auch
mann
ich brauche noch vier strings der noch
zwei scheiße ich jetzt bombay oder sagte
zumwinkel
vermehrt menschen wie viele hofft ich
möchte nicht vermengen
jetzt ging's los
nix da man wer hat denn je doch
irgendwie strings oder so oder sind sie
vielleicht irgendwann gäste hier drin ja
auch immer mal ein nein vielleicht auch
mit denen auch schon drin
nein die goldene feder das theoretisch
könnte ich ja jetzt ja gut da ich gucke
jetzt einfach bei zombie nämlich
machbare wie einfach
nz übrigens bisher ist die folge echt
doof aber ich habe mir eine private
rüstung gemacht und das auf jeden fall
schon mal ganz gut
einfach keine sachen dann mache ich
einfach bei broken fünf leute haben die
denn überhaupt strings das sind die
haben so und man sieht das richtig die
haben alles mögliche aber alles aus
irgendwelchen dungeons ich glaube ich
gebe halt auch einfach mal loslegen
dungeons und dann stehe ich da mein
leben an mir alle sachen die es gibt
was soll dass dieser keine strings
3 hab mir drei screens geburt dank will
man das kann doch nicht sein das ist
jetzt daran geguckt das ist dass gerade
jetzt hab ich night vision
deshalb hat jetzt an dem string um ein
gotteslob noch einmal nach ich wollte
mir auch noch eigentlich von links holen
schoko oder erzieherin wenn ich also das
sind sachen ich glaube da heute keine
irgendwie hinterher wenn doch tut es mir
leid
hab auf sagt nein
mappus regt mich eigentlich mehr auf als
das etwas bringt wenn man ihnen ihre
höhle ist oder so was bringt nämlich so
phoenix feder heißt es dass ich dann in
die wiederbeleben können ich glaube die
bieter hatte so eine
wer die bibel in unserem kampf sondern
schon weg war oder irgendwie sowas aber
ich frag mich halt einfach was das
bringt doch ich blöd man vergisst ihr
mal die hälfte
jacobo feder steering wolle wolle leder
koubek und schoko sattel so
so konnte er da rein und du kommst hier
oben rein vom star hin
damit gehe ich jetzt ein schoko ich muss
ja nicht wieder mitnehmen so und dann
machen eigentlich hat weil danach haben
wir eigentlich wieder alles also das ist
jetzt mein zweites tokio was ich mir in
dieser form hier hole mein drittes ich
weiß nicht welches hinnehmen ich möchte
eigentlich ein weißes da ist aber dass
das überall schon satteldorf was bringt
ein schwarzes ich guck mal ganz kurz
nach eben hexe chocobo ein bisschen
angst dass sie jetzt gleich in die
monster kommen euch sehe alles und hier
steht gerade in grüner vor mir
doch ob man hier steht einfach nichts
drin schlechter mit sauerstoff gerade
ein bisschen dreck black and the ability
to jump heiklen crosswater fest ist die
write once daily motion factory ja ich
wohl mit schwarzem chillig ist okay toki
nummer drei
keiner wird jetzt irgendwie zu töten und
ich werde selbst auch nicht erstellen
goldene feder ist kein fall schaden mehr
ich habe die kill beste rüstung quasi
die es gibt
ich habe richtig geil das turbo ja auch
richtig schnell ist er sie gerade aber
schon wieder wehgetan
der blaue augen post der gail sollte
nämlich noch immer eine show coupe die
wirtin und danach wieder geschlossen
ihr könnt mir weiterhin sachen in
kontakt auch diesen beiden ausgewachsen
das heißt es wird geputzt france jetzt
haben wieder nelly furtado und craig ist
immer der kleine eine kleine leute als
mindestens so
wikipedia ist der weg nach draußen
gefällt mir noch nicht richtig hier ich
muss das ganze noch mal ein bisschen
umbauen
es soll
der hatte doch gar keinen satteldorf hey
wieso hört der zombie na gut ich werde
dort zweimal fragen und euch dann morgen
bescheid darüber geben kann auch schon
sein dass der meckermann sorry ich habe
es nicht gesehen aber der hat keinen
sattel auf ich weiß es nicht ich muss
jetzt auch vom server herunter ich würde
sagen es euch gefallen habe ich mich
freuen sie ist am morgen wieder da wäre
ich das schoko problem auflösen und dann
tschüss